cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com from CBS News Ray Epps
protester at Center of January 6
far-right conspiracy charged over
Capital Riot and you see most people are
only going to see the headline and the
goal of this charge in my opinion
it's just it's obfuscation it's you know
the average person's gonna be like what
that guy he was criminally charged yeah
but come on here's the story Ray apps a
former Marine Trump supporter who became
the center of the January 6th conspiracy
theory has been charged in connection
with the Insurrection I like to call
that according to court documents filed
by the Department of Justice ABS is
charged with disorderly or disruptive
conduct on restricted grounds he's
expected to appear in court Wednesday
for a plea agreement
so let's just uh let's just point
something out
the FBI said Ray apps has never been an
FBI Source or an FBI employee I always
take issue with very specific answers
that nobody asked right because the
appropriate answer to the question of
was Ray apps involved with law
enforcement is Ray apps has zero
involvement or interaction with anyone
in law enforcement we don't know this
guy let's just make it unequivocally
clear this guy has nothing to do with us
or any other agency that we know of
instead it's like he wasn't a source or
an employee okay was he informant was he
a contractor well come on did he become
an informant later on I mean look I I
don't want to be too conspirators
because they didn't give a good enough
statement or a clear enough statement
but the issue I see here is you've got
people like Owen Shroyer who's being
sentenced as he was sentenced to 60 days
in prison and the federal government
cited his speech before during and after
his speech after the fact was cause for
him to go to prison but Ray Epps on the
day of telling people to go to the
Capitol and the night before saying to
go into the capital doesn't matter at
all in his sentencing to be there at the
front lines tearing down the barricades
he wasn't the one who physically did it
but the people in front of him did he
whispered the guy's ear he tears it down
then they Rush In And they're like one
charge meanwhile there's a journalist
named Stephen Stephen horn I believe his
name is four charges and he was and he
was just convicted and will not be
sentenced to prison
so something doesn't add up I don't know
what it is you know I'm not saying this
guy is a fed or anything like that I'm
just saying something is weird about
this story do they come from are there
different prosecutors going after these
people like because these are all spread
out over time right these these
convictions or these uh I mean it's been
two and a half years yeah so there are
different prosecutors and different
judges yeah yeah so this could that play
a role in here is there is there
something to do with leniency or such in
sentencing for these things I I really
doubt it I mean look you've got people
who walked on the grass confused who
were charged and sentenced to a month or
two you've got you've got uh uh uh
what's I'm forgetting John strand I
think his name was am I getting his name
wrongly I'm not getting his name wrong
sure three years convicted he was there
as a security guard working for Dr
Simone gold he wasn't there in any
political capacity he was just walking
around as a security guard
and they gave him three years yet
they're and and they're gonna give this
guy one charge we didn't tario get like
20 20. he wasn't even there yeah and he
got like a bunch of years in prison yeah
is what they do though you know I'm
gonna use the word lot probably tonight
but hypocrisy is the rule of the day for
these people and you got so much stuff
on this guy yeah so much stuff on him
the video footage is undeniable and yet
one charge he's gonna slap on the rest
nothing will happen to him it's just it
drives me crazy what's going on in our
country right now I would have thought
they would have arrested him and then
made it been like we're charging him
we're giving him 20 years and then like
steal him out of prison in the night and
send him to an island to live forever
like didn't they used to do that they'd
put people in witness protection or
something if they use them for a purpose
but this maybe they just feel like with
internet they can't you can't hide
people anymore you can't track it so
let's just blatantly use this guy to
incite I'm this is a guess but if he's
he's on the floor inciting and he didn't
get the book thrown at him there's
something going on and it just smells
like a uh some sort of red flag
maybe the conspiracy is because here's
my issue with conspiracy theories
everybody just assumes they know what
the outcome is but you don't so there's
the first thing is people are like okay
something doesn't make sense here and
then they say okay now I know for sure
what the answer is no no here's a
conspiracy theory for you the feds
intentionally under charged the guy to
make him the focal point of conspiracy
theories so that people aren't actually
looking at who may have really been
there there's a video from one
journalist showing a guy breaking out a
window and then as soon as the guy
realizes being filmed immediately stops
and then starts pushing someone else
accusing the other guy of breaking the
window like you see that one's more
interesting to me right UPS is on camera
saying stupid things if he was actually
an informant or fed or some kind of
plant or provocateur he would not be on
camera doing these things and then you
have other people who are on camera
doing things who get scared the moment
they realize they're being filmed and
stop yeah that is more those are the
ones you got to watch but I mean look if
someone if someone is there either as a
professor Couture or an intentional
rioter or maybe even insurrectionist
they're going to be if they're smashing
out a window they're going to stop and
then act like they weren't doing
anything wrong because they don't want
to get in trouble right it doesn't
matter if you're a fed or not I just
think it's weird that Ray apps would
would just stand there while people are
filming him outright saying constantly
but what about the woman that got shot
that's just sort of disappeared too she
was doing nothing Ashley yeah and she
gets shot and killed and the video
footage of her she wasn't doing anything
and nothing happened to the gentleman
that shot her I was right I think he had
a promotion I think he probably did yeah
the argument it's like the studio Chiefs
in Universal they just they fail
upwardly but go ahead
uh that she was climbing climbing over a
barricade so threatening their she
wasn't climbing over a barricade she was
looking through a window yeah she
climbed up she stood on she stood on the
uh like framing of the window and then
looked through the window and then it
was like they'll put a button a broken
window so there's like a hole they
probably thought she was climbing
through I mean the window was not that
big her face could barely be seen
through it they put a bullet in her neck
there's no reason the guy the guy the
cop was panicked and freaked out it's
dangerous to have people like that
holding weapons but those are the things
that happen I didn't hear any defund the
police calls after that one surprisingly
dude the raps think it's the most nuts I
mean just beyond nuts thing this guy's
screaming for people to go to the
Capitol to get Rowdy I don't know all
the quotes but some of the stuff you
mentioned he texted his nephew saying he
orchestrated it
what in the hell he's like yep and uh he
even says in one of the videos he he's
like he doesn't want to say it because
he'll get arrested but he's gonna say it
anyway it's like okay and then he took
him two and a half years to get one
misdemeanor charge you have people you
had that lady I love referencing this
the the feds broke into they stormed
into her house in Alaska because she
looked like a different lady
so there was a woman who was in the
Capitol they were like hey we think this
is the person so they break into this
other lady's house but the guy who's on
camera and citing everybody to do it
it's like nah no no worries here man how
long ago was he charged like are
initially charged right absolutely yeah
today it was just today right so is it
possible that he's going to end up uh
informing
I think I think the potential the
reality here may be he's been in
informant the whole time the whole time
and uh maybe not for the FBI or
something like that it could be it could
be Capital police and so the FBI says
he's never been a source or an employee
what does source mean does source
include informant it's an opinion
statement so it could or could not their
quotes meaningless to me but it could
have been the Capitol Police I I wonder
if it's possible because he used to be
an oath keeper if you know originally he
was on the website for like people of
Interest they were looking for and they
took him off I wonder if they found him
right away they found him right away
here's he's on camera everywhere saying
this they instantly are like we got a
clear picture of his face then they went
to him and said you are going to inform
and provide testimony on all these
people that bolster our cases or you're
going to go to prison forever and he
said I'll do whatever you said okay I
didn't know he was an oath keeper before
that makes a lot of sense yeah
so what about what about all these guys
I mean the little segue but still on the
same track what you know what happened
January 6th all these antifa guys the
video footage of them changing in the
clothes and Trump closing I saw a lot of
the footage I don't know if that's real
or not I've seen the footage too but I
don't know what it is and these are
these are the challenges right you've
got the the pipe bomb guy I know
everybody found you've got the video of
changing their clothes and putting on
you know like they're taking off hoodies
and putting on like Trump Trump's
looking clothes and there's no
motivation for prosecutors to want to do
anything about it because that's not the
way that the political winds are blowing
right now ah the political Winds Don't
Blow That Way in general ever yeah no
so there you go I don't know man uh this
is only resulting in more people
believing that there's a conspiracy
theory here but I wonder if if you're
gonna actually believe that the
intelligence agencies are capable of
doing anything you have to operate the
assumption that they're going to be a
little bit smarter it's not like a
random guy just being like I know let's
let's have our friends smash a window
and then we can blame other people for
it and there's gonna be a little bit
more to it than that in which case the
right app stuff is a very very Hefty
distraction everybody's pointing the
finger at this guy and he's just
as far as we can see a doofy trump
supporter who for some reason is not
getting prosecuted and so maybe in his
mind he's like why is everyone coming
after me and if there really was an
intelligence operation you've got guys
like you mentioned changing their
clothes yeah and everyone's just like
raps raps raps well there's a lot of uh
FBI guys apparently right yeah I mean
they were widely reported especially
with the proud boys like dozens I don't
know what the exact number is but FBI
informants up the Wazoo with the proud
boys I lovely blame Trump I mean you saw
him speaking he's on camera saying go
peacefully if you're gonna go down there
he didn't say anything about rioting and
if he still gets blame for it doesn't
matter because they just they go after
everything for him I mean he said seven
straight years of being attacked it's
pretty incredible to have that much hate
centered on you for that long it's
incredible yeah Dark Days man because
you look at the stuff going on there's
this guy Stephen horn journalist
objectively a journalist and I mean like
he's not I'm not saying objective
journals I'm saying objectively when you
look at the facts as a journalist and I
guess they got him because when he was
in he went in the capital filming and he
chanted USA USA USA oh now he's
demonstrating so they got him they got
four charges uh entering a remaining
restricted area disorderly disruptive
conduct and restricted area disorderly
conducting a capital building parading
demonstrating or picketing in a capitol
building so to be fair he was in the
Capitol building and so you might say
those two charges related to being
inside rehabs is not going to get but
Ray app still only got one charge he
didn't he didn't even get charged with
entering restricted area despite the
fact he incited everyone to go do it in
the first place
it feels like that's the more serious
charge right would be the incitement of
others to do so because they seem to use
that as their kind of barometer for
where to charge right it's inciting an
Insurrection so if the guy's got if he's
actually saying he orchestrated this
stuff they can't they can't charge him
you know why because Trump's the one in
their minds or Trump's the one they need
to have legally on the books as having
orchestrated it that's what I'm saying
because like when when they were talking
about initially like you said when
they're ignoring what his actual words
were and they're saying that he incited
that's the language they kept using
right he was inciting an Insurrection
this could be the reason why they don't
charge him and they're or they're
holding off on charging because they
know the evidence would show he not only
admitted to orchestrating it in attacks
between a family member but he's on
camera and citing people and they need
Trump to have been the guy so they can
get him off the ballot yeah they'll just
end up in the same cell together him and
Trump and uh Trump and this guy will
just end up having to serve their terms
I don't know what they're gonna do with
Trump you can't put them in prison but
they can't they're not going to let him
run like they're not going to let him
win I don't know do you think he ends up
on the ballot Trump yeah well what does
that mean what state where do you think
that do you think he'll be wrong Trump
will be removed from I don't know about
enough isn't it doesn't matter Trump I I
believe it is a high probability Trump
is removed from from the ballot
somewhere really yeah I mean look at I
mean Arizona wouldn't it would not
surprise me if come October of next year
Trump's name is just not on the ball in
Arizona because we know they print with
Kate with uh with the uh Hobbs versus
Lake election the wrong ballot sizes
were printed on the wrong paper yeah and
it jammed up the machines so if they can
do that and then go Whoopsie Daisy and
then nothing happens there's no
reconciliation there's no accountability
at all then well they'll take Trump's
name off somewhere and just go it's a
good carrying your show oh yeah several
times she's awesome she's great she's
great and and she does have a bunch of
Victories right now too so I don't I
don't act like nothing's happening yeah
they recently ruled that the signature
verification in Arizona was well it's
unbelievably obvious and then once again
we talked about this early I was driving
in here with with your with your
transportation guy it was awesome and we
talked about the in craziness of the
just mail and voting and neither side is
fighting to get rid of it I don't see I
don't see anybody on the right getting
rid of it get rid of it the Wild Kratts
are fighting for it the Democrats I know
yeah but no they want to keep it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time